president Trump
will you come speak to US president
Trump Donald Trump has been charged with
34 felony counts of falsifying business
records to hide hush money payments
these are felony crimes in New York
state
no matter who you are
court documents state that Trump
repeatedly and fraudulently falsified
New York business records to conceal
criminal conduct that hid damaging
information from the voting public
during the 2016 presidential election
Trump pleaded not guilty in a Manhattan
courtroom on Tuesday and has said the
probe by the office of Manhattan
district attorney Alvin Bragg a Democrat
is politically motivated Ashby Jones who
is part of the journal team that
originally uncovered the payoffs
explains the details of the case and the
newly unsealed charges
Mr Trump is accused of having violated
the law when he arranged hush money
payments to go from the organization he
ran the Trump organization through
Michael Cohen his former attorney to a
woman named Stormy Daniels just before
the 2016 elections falsifying business
record charges are not normally felonies
in New York state court it's not
entirely clear from the documents that
were revealed how we get from
misdemeanor to felony charges but one
accepted theory is that the
falsification of the business records
were connected to an attempt to cover up
a crime a separate crime that in itself
would Elevate business record
misdemeanors to low levels of felonies
called Class E felonies the crime that
is alleged to have been covered up with
the falsification of these business
records were campaign Finance violations
or in other words payments that were
made over and above campaign Finance
contribution limits in the run-up to the
2016 election
one of the things that Alvin Bragg is
going to have to prove or show is that
these payments were actually connected
back up to Donald Trump also it's a
really untested legal Theory to connect
a business records fraud violation back
up to a campaign finance charge and to
connect the dots there to bring what
would be a misdemeanor charge into the
realm of a felony the defense has ample
opportunity to look forward and really
build their defense I think we're going
to see a flurry of motions a motion to
dismiss an indictment could come down
before too long we could see a motion to
change venue we're not probably going to
see a trial for many many months as much
as a year Donald Trump it looks like
he's going to have his his hands quite
full he's involved and embroiled in a
lot of other legal issues at this point
I think this is all just going to be
something that he and his team are going
to have to wrestle with moving
throughout the rest of 2023 and into
2024 when campaign season really starts
to heat up